إنها محاولة وحشية
للمضايقة وبقي سايلنت
يتحدث نيابة عن مرضاي نيابة عن
الجرحى هنا نيابة عن
هذه العائلات التي يتم تدميرها، كما تعلمون أن
هناك 50 عائلة
تم مسحها من السجل المدني
مما يعني أن الأجداد والآباء
والأحفاد قتلوا جميعًا
الأطفال الذين أعالجهم كل
هذا يعني أنه من واجبي كطبيب ومن
واجبي أن أتحمل بالنبيذ
نوع المذبحة التي
ترتكب ضدهم حتى لا
توقف، وهذا النوع من تكتيكات الشرطة
أعنيه وكما لو أن زوجتي لم يكن لديها ما
يكفي للقلق بشأن أه، كان عليها أن
تتحمل هذا اليوم، وقد تم
تناوله الآن من قبل المحامين من قبل
محاميك نعم حسنًا، أعني أنا  بحاجة
لمعرفة سبب اعتقاد شخص ما أنها ستكون
فكرة جيدة أن يحضروا إلى
منزلي ويسألوا زوجتي عن أي جزء من
المستشفى أنا فيه ولماذا ذهبت ومن دفع ثمن
تذكرتي وأي جزء من المستشفى  مؤسسة خيرية
أعمل من أجلها في هذا الوقت في هذه
الأوقات الصعبة التي تعيشها عائلتي وترى
هذا القصف يتكشف وأنا أعلم
جيدًا أنني في وسطه، لذا فإن
مضايقتهم في هذه الموجة أمر
غريب حقًا